hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where us gamespot nerds and you nerd out
over the things that we like and today
we're talking about the walking dead the
latest episode is called go-getters so
let's jump in alright guys let's talk so
Maggie had a big episode last night she
was an attractor she ran over some stuff
yeah she ran over some stuff she
defended hilltop um so what do you
think's next for Maggie Maggie's gonna
take command I think she's definitely
gonna be the top dog cuz Gregory's not
gonna do it Gregory is a dog to the
Savior's and I room it and I'm really
hoping that Maggie and Jesus both set up
a kind of a coalition together so they
can then join up with alexandria later
down the road and the kingdom to kind of
form that align so we saw in the comic I
liked so I would really like to see that
it's good to see Maggie taking command
now she's not morning anymore people are
kind of tired of that like Glenn's gone
right now I'm gonna you know focus on
building back up the hill top and are we
getting he came back for what he did
right there was one line that really was
evidence for that um you know it was
like are you okay and she was like no
but I will be yeah so that's that's
gonna fix things and her child survived
too which is good although there's a
really interesting tension this episode
didn't address which is that she doesn't
know she's supposed to be dead right so
she was separated from the group she
went to hilltop and they went back to
Alexandria where Ric lied to negan about
her being dead so if she takes over at
hilltop negan is gonna know that Ric
lied so she doesn't know that she could
potentially get Rick killed if she does
follow through taking over hilltop that
could be a lot of trouble oh no okay
speaking of Carl so let's talk about
Carl and Rick well they had an
interesting interesting relationship on
this episode because we saw Carl kind of
like standing up against negan screw and
it's almost like he still doesn't get
like hasn't processed to the vest of
Glenn and um Abraham Abraham so it's it
I still don't get why he's still going
against that I guess against the grain
and Rick's trying to convince them in
this episode to just follow his lead
follow so that no one else gets killed
and he eventually does but we see later
in this episode that he's in the truck
with Jesus that we can get to it which
we hopefully see that now it's gonna
fall more the comic because now we get
to see that weird friendship that negan
forms with Carl when he sees Carl you
know taking action against his crew
which I'm really hoping and I'm sure a
lot people are too that we can finally
get to see that that weird friendship
that forges I was in the comic so what
we can see is that what you're hoping to
see I'm hoping that's what i can see
because i really want to see some more
character dynamics between the two of
them because that's that's just so
powerful in the book and we have a
really touched base on that yet and this
in the show so I'm really hoping that
happens for this so what's Carl's next
move here do you think he's in the truck
he's in the truck what's his plan well
his plan is to get negan and to end
obviously figure out what's going on
behind all this and who knows maybe a
rescue of Daryl might be in the process
of this you never know but I think what
really will happen is is that he's going
to wind up killing a few of negan screw
to get to negan maybe even get a shot
off at negan and then we'll just see
what happens to him from there I'm just
hoping Carl grows up a little bit it was
like sale near church so it feels like
he's three seasons ago right it doesn't
help that he was on roller skates for a
part of yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's that's cute and all but yeah just
grow up he needs to grow up fast cuz in
this world you have yes take off the Hat
cut your hair grow up look at it it's
our message to Carl right now let's talk
about Simon Aaron yeah it's interesting
Simon is known Egan I think we keep
seeing that negan may have been looking
for another second in command when he
went after Rick because Simon sort of
tries the mannerisms of negan but he's
not that intimidating really he's he's
intimidating because he came with a
hundred guys negan is intimidating
because he's needed and he screws with
people's heads so you can see him like
try something out and not have it not
quite work like oh please give this to
me no I mean like give it to me you know
he's like try as you assert himself um
and also like this whole idea that you
know working with Simon's crew we see
him and different work with different
settlements and the question is whether
if he and this is what Karl's dealing
with two if you
work with them are they reasonable I
think that's the big question that we
have right now so he comes in the
hilltop and he takes half their stuff
which was the original pitch they had
but if you're taking half of someone's
stuff and then you take half of that you
take half of that and you take half of
that suddenly it's not so reasonable
anymore because that's exponential
you're just taking all of their stuff at
some point that's just bullying yeah so
no it doesn't add up I think what
everybody's dealing with at this point
besides just the intimidation of their
crew is like can you work with them are
they reasonable people to work with once
you start obeying their rules right you
can definitely see a buildup of
something's going to happen that's going
to snap Rick screw hilltop because all
the sharing all this what you know half
is mine kind of thing that's not gonna
last and I definitely see Simon being
one of the people who might wind up you
know killing someone either from hilltop
Orleans Alexandria just try to assert
his dominance that you know I'm right
there knee gan's you know level two just
to prove a point and that could wind up
you know starting the whole thing
because something's definitely I think
gonna happen sooner or later to kind of
break all this you know locomotion very
slow buildup of setting stuff up because
I don't know that this episode was was a
little too slow for my comfort as slow
as that tractor chase with the zombies
yeah don't mind me of that Austin piracy
yes so predictions for next week anybody
I definitely never lessee Carl doing
making a move against negan it wasn't
really heightened very much it was
mostly on neck Tara trying to find her
way through a forest be obviously being
chased by both the dead and who's
hunting her that's another thing too is
like who who's going after her maybe
another group maybe it might be a friend
and we don't know well they lost all
their guns in a previous episode and
they still have to go get stuff for
negan which means that they're sort of
defenseless hmm so I'm guessing she went
out to get stuff for negan probably you
hear Rick say oh man we only have one
more data to deliver yeah it's like what
we were gonna do like we gotta find
something and that could kind of push
her over the edge to find out what you
need to do because she's obviously in
danger in this episode like she's hiding
from from something or someone so what
who knows I'm wondering if we're gonna
get a death before the mid-season finale
because the mid season finales like that
point where it gets really dark and
something big happened
something big always happens any
predictions right now let's put our bets
on this poker table right here who is
dying next you know I would definitely
say maybe a lower echelon character like
maybe Tara or someone who is important
to the group and not I would say as high
level as like Glenn was just so we could
just get the ball rolling which then
leads back to my thought about Simon
being the one to do it because he could
like I said he could be exerting his you
know trying to assert his dominance or
maybe Maggie makes the first move maybe
she gets enough people to follow her
it's just something needs to really kick
this thing into high gear in my opinion
to kind of move get the ball rolling you
guys think I think it's all gonna end in
Nagin's town I mean that's where all the
the characters who don't really care
about what happens are all heading there
and i have a feeling that's where the
season will end is with a siege of his
territory mm-hmm any death predictions
i'm thinking maybe Enid ah maybe it's a
character that we've seen pop up more
and more and kind of I'm thinking that
she could be one of those that that gets
killed off at the mid-season because we
care about her but she's not as big of a
characters main cast so maybe that's
just enough to push Karl over into
growing up yeah and I'm thinking that's
where he might grow up might actually
all of the deaths might finally get to
him God where he like he said to me in
the episode he watched those deaths he
didn't look away yeah but in still he
hasn't grown up and this one will push
him to finally get a haircut and finally
get rid of or I'll get a haircut will
okay the next episode is called swear so
who's gonna die let us know in the
comments below I'd really like to see
zombie Karl on the roller skates with
the head on that would be pretty funny
so leave your comments and questions
down below and we'll include you next
time and for all things nerding out
tuning to gamespot universe
[Music]
you